The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMNON SHASHUA: So
unlike most of the talks
that you have been
given, I'm not
going to teach you
anything today.
So it's not kind going to
be teaching type of talk.
It will be more towards let's
look at the crystal ball
and try to see how
the future will unfold
and future where computer
vision is a major agent
in this transformative future.
So I'll start with
transportation.
This is the field where
Mobileye is active.
And then I'll move towards
wearable computing, the field
where OrCam is active.
These are two companies
that I co-founded.
One, Mobileye in 1999
and OrCam in 2010.
So before I just-- a few words
about the computer vision.
I'm assuming that you all
know about computer vision.
It's the science
of making computers
see and extract meaning out
of images, out of video.
This is a field that
in the past 20 years,
through machine learning,
has made a big jump.
And in the past four years,
through deep learning,
has made another jump where
there are certain narrow areas
in computer vision
and perception
where computers reach
human level perception
and even surpass it.
Like facial recognition
is one of those areas.
And the belief is that in many
narrow areas in computer vision
within the next five years we'll
be able to reach human level
perception.
So it's a major branch of AI.
It goes together
with machine learning
and as said, a major progress.
And one very
important thing, which
is relevant to the industrial
impact of computer vision
is that cameras
are the lowest cost
sensor that you can imagine.
A camera sensor
costs a few dollars.
A lens costs a few dollars.
All the rest is computing.
And every sensor
needs computing.
So if you can reach human
level perception with a camera
you have a sensor that
the cost is so low
that it can be everywhere.
And that this is very--
this is very important.
So I'll show you where
things are standing in terms
of avoiding a collision.
So avoiding collision,
you have a camera.
Behind the windscreen
looking, facing forward,
analyzing the video
coming from the camera.
And the purpose of this
analysis is to avoid collisions.
So what does it mean
to avoid collisions?
The software needs
to detect vehicles,
it need to detect pedestrians,
need to detect traffic lines,
traffic signs, need to
detect traffic lights,
detect lanes, to know where
the car is positioned relative
to the lanes.
And then send a signal to
the car control systems
to avoid an accident.
So let's look under the
hood what this means.
So I'll let this run a bit until
all the information appears.
So if we stop here,
what do we see?
So the bounding
boxes around cars
means that the system
has detect cars.
Red means that this
vehicle is in our path.
The green line here is
the detection of the lane.
This is a traffic--
this is a no entry traffic sign.
This is a traffic light
being detected here.
These are the
pedestrians and cyclists.
Even a pedestrian standing
here is being detected.
Let's no-- let this
run a bit further.
All right.
So these pedestrians
crossing the street.
So this is running at
about 36 frames per second.
So now imagine also the
amount of computations
that are being running here.
Again, this is the traffic sign,
traffic light, pedestrians,
pedestrians here.
So this is-- this is what
the system does today,
detect objects,
detect lane marks,
measure distances
to the objects.
And in case you are
about to hit an object,
the car would engage.
Engage, at first it
will give warnings.
Then later it will apply
automatic autonomous braking
in order to avoid the accident.
And here is a list of
many, many functions
that the camera does
in terms of detecting
objects and detecting--
trying to interpret
the visual field at details that
are increasing over the years.
Now computer vision is
also creating a disruption.
So if you would ask an
engineer say, 15 years ago,
what is a camera good
for in this space?
The engineer would
say the camera
is good for detecting lanes.
Because there's no
other sensor that can,
you know, find the lane marks,
not a radar, not a laser
scanner.
And it may be good for helping
the radar infusion-- radar
camera fusion to compensate
for shortcomings of the radar.
Traffic signs, OK it, will
be good for traffic signs.
But that's it.
But what happened
over the years is
that the camera slowly
started taking territory
from the radar.
Until today, the camera is
really the primary sensor
for active safety.
Active safety is all this
area for avoiding accidents.
And you can see this
through this chart.
So in 2007, now we launched
the first camera radar fusion.
So there's no disruption there.
This is what normally people
would think a camera is good
for, combining with a radar.
2008, camera is also doing
traffic sign recognition.
No disruption there.
2010, camera's doing
pedestrian detection.
No disruption there
because there's
no other sensor that can
reliably detect pedestrians.
Because they emit radar
very, very weakly.
And pedestrians mostly
stationary object.
And radars are not good at
detecting stationary objects.
But then in 2011,
there's the first camera
only forward collision warning.
And that was the
beginning of a disruption.
So forward collision warning
is detect a vehicle in front
and provide a warning if
you are about to collide
with a vehicle.
And this was a
function that typically
was in the territory of radars.
So a radar sensor is very
good at detecting vehicles,
very good at ranging,
very, very accurately can
get the range of a vehicle,
say 100 meters away up
to an accuracy of
a few centimeters.
No camera can reach
those accuracies.
So nobody believed that one
day a camera will take over
the radar and do this function.
And this is what
happened in 2011.
And why did this happen?
This happened because of
a commercial constraint.
The regulator, the
American regulator,
it's National Highway Safety
Transportation Agency,
NHSTA, decided that by 2011 all
cars need to have as an option
two functions, forward collision
warning and lane departure
warning.
Now this creates a problem
because forward collision
warning requires a radar.
Lane departure warning
requires a camera.
So now put two sensors in
the car, it's expensive.
If you can do it with one
sensor, like with a camera,
then you save a lot of money.
So this pushed the car
industry to adopt the idea
that the camera can do
forward collision warning.
And like all disruptions,
once you start small
you kind of grow
very, very fast.
So in 2013 the
camera is not only
providing warning,
but also safe distance
keeping to the car in front.
It's called adaptive
cruise control.
Then 2013 also provides
emergency braking.
So the camera not only
decides that you're
about to collide with
a vehicle, it will also
apply the brakes for you.
So 2013 was only
partial braking.
So to avoid the accident up
to 30 kilometers per hour.
And then in 2015, this
was few months ago,
the camera is now
involved in full braking.
It's one G-Force of braking
avoiding an accident of about
70 - 80 kilometers per hour.
And mitigating an
accident up to 220
kilometers per hour,
just the camera.
So the camera is taking over
and becoming the primary sensor
in this area of active safety.
Now, why is that?
As I said, these are the
milestones of the camera
disruption, is first the
camera has the highest density
of information as a sensor.
You know, laser
scanner or radar,
the amount of pixels
per angle, per degree
is much, much smaller.
It's orders of magnitude
smaller than a camera.
So you have a lot, a lot of
information from the camera.
It's the lowest cost sensor.
And also the cameras are getting
better in terms of performance
under low light.
So with a camera today
you can do much more,
not only because computing
has progressed, not only
because algorithms
are now better,
but also because the
physics of the camera
are progressing over
time, especially
the light sensitivity
of the camera.
So we also came
to the conclusion
that we need to build our own
hardware and our own chip.
And these are very, very
advanced microprocessors
that they can per silicon
area are about 10 times more
efficient than any
general purpose chip.
And I'll not spend
more time on this.
And so this field
has two major trends.
One, on the left hand
side, is the active safety,
which is driven by regulators.
So the regulators see that
there is a sensor that is
very low cost and saves lives.
So what does the regular do?
They incentivize this kind of
function to the car industry
by coupling it to star ratings.
So if you want to get your four
star or five stars the NCAP
stars on the car, you have to
have this kind of technology
as a standard fit in the car.
So this pushes the
industry by mandates.
It pushes the industry to
have active safety installed
in every car.
So by 2018 every new car
would have such a system.
The left hand side is
the trend to the future,
which is autonomous driving.
Now autonomous driving
has two facets.
One is bringing the
probability of an accident
to infinitesimally
small probability.
So zero-- zero accidents.
Because the more you
delegate the driving
experience to a robotic
system, the less
the chance of an accident.
So it brings us to an era where
there will be no accidents.
But not less importantly,
it has the potential
to transform the entire
transportation business.
How we own cars,
how we build cars,
the number of cars
that would be produced.
And I'll spend a bit more time
about that as I go forward.
Now, in terms of the left
hand side, the regulation,
this is an example.
So you see here a Nissan
Qashquai 2014 has five stars.
And to know how to get the
five stars what you see here,
these are all the tests.
These are autonomous
emergency braking tests.
The car needs to detect the
car in front, the target car,
and apply the brakes
before the collision.
And the car is being tested.
And without that they'll
not get the five stars.
You can see this also
in the number of chips
that have been shipped.
So every car has a chip.
So this chip, the
microprocessor,
is getting the information
from the camera
and all the algorithms are
on this microprocessor.
So we started
launching this in 2007.
So in the first five years
there were one million chips,
so one million cars
with the technology.
And then in 2013
alone, 1.3 million.
Then you see here, 2014, 2.7.
This year is going to
be about five million.
So you see this doubling.
And this is really the
effect of the regulation.
So in many industries
regulation is an impediment.
In this industry, regulation
is something good.
It pushes the industry to
install these kinds of systems,
you know, standard.
OK.
So another example of how
this is moving, there's
also an increasing awareness.
So this is a commercial from
2014 Super Bowl by Hyundai.
So Hyundai is showcasing their
new vehicle called Genesis.
Now, there are many
things that you
can show when you want to
showcase a new vehicle.
You can talk about the
design of the vehicle.
You could talk about the
engine, the infotainment.
But they chose to talk
about the active safety.
So I'll show you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Remember when only
Dad could save the day?
Auto emergency braking on the
all new Genesis from Hyundai.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMNON SHASHUA: OK.
So this is the camera
behind the windscreen,
detecting the car in
front, or a pedestrian,
and will break
before the collision.
Now to show you
what this is about--
so that was the commercial.
So in a commercial you can
show anything you like.
So now I'll show you something
really from the field.
So in 2010 Volvo introduced
the first pedestrian detection.
So the same thing,
detect a pedestrian
and if you are about to collide
with a pedestrian the car would
brake, apply the
brakes automatically.
So in 2010 they had about
5,000 journalistic events,
where they put a reporter
behind the steering wheel,
tell the reporter to
drive towards a mannequin,
toward a doll, and
low and behold the car
would brake just before--
a fraction of a second
before you hit the doll.
But then when you buy the car
you can do your own testing.
So I downloaded
from the internet,
its a bunch of Polish guys.
And it's a bit funny
but you'll actually
get a good feeling of
what this system does
by looking at this clip.
OK?
So this is automatic
emergency braking.
Today it works, it
avoids accidents
about 70 kilometers per hour.
OK?
So now you have a better idea
of what I'm talking about.
So now let's go into the future.
So this was just
setting the baseline.
OK.
What is active safety?
Where's computer
vision inside this?
So now let's look in
the next four years.
And the idea is to evolve
this kind of technology
to a point where you
can delegate the driving
experience to a robotic system.
And then the question is,
what needs to be done.
And this slide shows that
there are two paradigms.
And the reality is somewhere
in between these two paradigms.
The right hand side
is where we are today.
You are based only on sensing.
You have camera.
Maybe you have also a radar, or
laser scanner for redundancy.
You get the information
from the sensors.
You have algorithms that try
to interpret the visual field
and take action in
case of an accident,
or control the vehicle.
On the left hand side
is the extreme case,
is the Google approach,
where there is little
sensing involved.
It's a lot of recording.
So you prerecord your drive.
Once you have prerecorded the
drive all what you need to do
is to match your sensing
to the prerecorded drive.
Once you've found the match,
you know your position exactly.
So you don't need to
know to detect lanes.
You know all the moving objects.
Because the recording contains
only stationary objects.
So all the moving
objects pop out.
So that the load on the
sensing is much, much smaller
than in the case where
you didn't do it pre-drive
and you didn't record.
This recording, the
problem with the recording,
is that we are talking
about tons of data.
It's a 360 degree, 3D recording,
at several frames per second.
So the amount of data is huge.
So there's issues of how you
manage this, how you record it,
and how you update
this over time.
Because you have to continuously
update this kind of data.
And reality is going to
be somewhere in between.
So the first leap that is
undergoing and happening
in the next five years is to
reach human level perception.
Now it sounds very,
very ambitious.
But there's lots of indications
that it is not science fiction.
It is really-- there is
a very high probability
that one can reach this.
So in certain areas,
like face recognition,
certain categorization tasks--
now if you look at the
academic achievements,
they have surpassed
human level perception.
I'll spend a few
slides on this later.
So going from adaptive--
going from driver assist
to human level perception,
first, we need to extend
the list of objects.
Not only vehicles
and pedestrians,
but vehicles at any angles, know
about 1,000 different object
categories in the
scene, know about how
to predict a path using context,
which today is not being used.
Detailed road
interpretation, knowing
about curbs and
barriers and guards,
it's all the stuff that when we
look at the road we naturally
interpret it very, very easily.
These are the things that needs
to be done in order to reach
human level perception.
And the tool to do this is
the deep layered networks,
which I'll spend a few slides
about this in a moment.
And the need for
context, so these
are examples, for
example, path planning.
You want to fuse
all the information
available from the image, not
only to look for the lanes,
because in many situations
you look at an image you
don't see lanes.
But a human observer
would very easily
know where the path is just
from looking at the context.
In modeling data environment,
ultimately every pixel
give you a category.
Tell me where this
pixel is coming from,
a pedestrian, from a
vehicle, from inside
of a vehicle, barrier,
curb, guardrail, lamp post,
so forth and so forth.
3D modeling of a vehicle.
So put a 3D bounding
box around the vehicle
so that we can know which side
of a vehicle I'm looking at,
whether it's the front,
or rear, left side,
right side, what is the angle.
Know everything about
vehicles as moving objects
and do a lot of
scene recognition.
I'll give some examples
about that later.
So just deep networks,
I know that you have--
you all know about
deep networks.
I'll just spend
a few slides just
to state what is
the impact there,
not the impact from the
point of view of a scientist,
but the impact from the point
of view of a technologist.
Because there isn't much
science behind this.
So the real turning
point was 2012.
2012, you know,
the AlexNet, they
show they built a
convolutional net that
was able to work on
the ImageNet data set
and reach a performance
level, which
was more or less
double the performance
level of what was done before.
This is another
network by Fergus.
Very, very similar concept
of convolution pooling.
Convolution pooling
two-three dense layers
and you get the output.
This is the ImageNet data set.
You have about 1,000 categories
over one million images.
And these categories
are very challenging.
You know, you look at the
images of a sailing vessel
or images of a husky,
the variation is huge.
It's a really very
difficult task.
2011 the top five--
so the task is that you need
to give a short list of five
categories.
And if the correct categories
is among the top five
then you succeeded.
And the performance
was about 26% error.
And this AlexNet reached 16%.
So it's almost double
the performance.
So this caught the
attention of the community.
It's a big leap from 26% to 16%.
Now if you look what happened
since then, so 2012 for this
ImageNet competition there
was one out of six competitors
use deep networks.
A year later 17 out of 24
competitors used deep networks.
A year later 31 out of
32 using deep networks.
So deep networks
took over basically.
If you look in terms
of the performance,
of the human
performance is about 5%.
And right now we are at 6%, 5%,
by the latest 2015 competitors.
People start cheating.
So I think this is
more or less Baidu was
caught cheating on this test.
So I think 5% is more or
less where things are going.
And this is human
level perception.
Another-- another big success
was the face recognition.
So this is a data set
called face recognition
in the wild, which contains
pictures of celebrities
where every celebrity you
have pictures, you know,
along a spectrum of
many, many years.
You can see the actor
when he was 20 years old
and then when he's
70-80 years old.
Even for humans, this
task is quite challenging,
knowing whether two pictures
are from the same person or not.
And the human level
performance is 97.5% correct.
Now if you look at techniques
not using deep networks,
they reached 91.4%.
And in 2014 a group by
Facebook and Lior Wolf
from Tel Aviv University,
they built a deep network
to do face recognition
and reached
97.3%, which is very, very
close to human perception.
And since then people have
reach 99% on this database.
And again, human level
perception is 97.5.
So this is another area where
these deep networks, also
in speech.
This is a recent paper by
Baidu headed by Andrew Ng.
They surpassed,
just doing an end
to end network which learns
also the structured prediction,
better performance than
Siri, Cortana, Google Now.
OK?
So the impact for
automotive is that networks
are very good at multi-class So
the more categories you have,
the better the performance
of the network would be.
Very good at using context,
imagining or planning a path.
So taking an image as an input
and output would be the path.
And you're cutting short
of all the processes
of looking for lanes and
this kind of algorithms.
Network will be ideal
for pixel level labeling.
For every pixel
give me a category.
And you can use the networks
for sensor integration,
for determining the control of
the vehicle by fusing a lot,
a lot of information coming
from various cameras.
So the challenge of
using deep networks
is that deep networks
are very, very large.
They're not designed
for real time.
The networks that you find in
academic papers and the success
are for easy problems.
The problems that
I've shown right now,
the ImageNet, the
face recognition,
are relatively
considered easy problems
in the context of interpreting
the image for autonomous
driving.
So let me show you what are
the things that one can do.
Let's start with
the path planning.
So this clip that I'll show you
here the purpose of the network
is to determine the path.
So this is the green line.
Now these clips are from
scenes where it will
be impossible to detect lanes.
Because there's simply
no-- simply no lanes.
If you look at this, any
lane detection system
would find nothing in
this kind of scene.
Yet when you look
at this image, you
have no problem in
determining where the path is.
Because you're looking at
the entire image context.
And this is what the
network is doing.
It's being fed the input
layer is the image,
the output layer
is this green line.
Or for example, if you
at this urban setting.
There are no lanes
in an urban setting.
Yet the system can
predict where the path
is by fusing information
from the entire context.
These are roads in
California where
they have these reflectors
called Botts dots.
It's almost impossible
to reliably, you know,
fit lanes to these
kinds of information.
Yet if you look at this
holistic path planning
it reliably can tell
you where it is.
Let's look at free space.
So free space, the
idea of when you
want to do autonomous
driving you
need to know where not to drive.
Right?
You don't want to
drive towards the curb.
It's not only that
you don't want
to hit other moving objects.
That's the easy part.
You don't want to hit a
barrier or a guardrail.
So you want to know
where the free space is.
So you can think of a
network that for every pixel
will give you a label.
And let's now focus only on the
label of road versus not road.
So all the pixel green are road.
Everything else is not road.
So you can see that
the green is not
going over the curb,
which is-- which is nice.
But let's have it
run a bit more.
And then I'll stop
it at the place
where you'll see where
the power of context.
Says let's assume
I stop it here.
Now look at the sidewalk there.
The color of the sidewalk
and the color of the road
is identical.
The height of the curb
is about one centimeter.
So it's not that the
height here, the geometry--
it's basically the context.
The network figured out because
there is a parked car there.
That part is not
part of the road.
So in order to make
this judgment correctly,
one needs to not just look at
a small area around the pixel
and decide whether
it's road or not road.
One needs to collect information
from the entire image.
This is the power of context.
And this is something
that the network can do.
You can see here, where
the blue and red lines.
Red means it's on a vehicle.
Blue that it's on
a physical barrier.
So if I run this back here--
and this is done frame by frame.
So it's a single frame thing.
Same thing here, this height
is one or two centimeters.
The color of the sidewalk and
the color of the road it's
identical.
So being able to make
the correct judgment here
is very, very challenging.
And this is where a
network can succeed.
Here the network also
predicts that this
is a code for being a curb.
The red is the side of a
vehicle or front of the vehicle.
And the next one it
predicts that this
is part of a guardrail,
the coding of this
is part of a guardrail.
So the system has
about 15 categories,
guardrail, curb,
barrier, and so forth.
Let's keep the
questions for later.
And so forth.
So this is one area we
call semantic free space.
So for every pixel in the
scene tell me what it is.
Of course, I'm
interested-- first
and foremost I'm interested
to know where the road is.
And then at the edges of where
the road ends to know what
is the label.
Is it a side of a vehicle,
front of a vehicle,
rear of a vehicle.
Is it a curb barrier
guardrail and so forth.
And this, again, is
done by deep network.
I'll skip this one.
And then you can apply this
from cameras from any angle.
So this is a camera
looking at a corner,
looking at the 45
degrees on the right.
So the system can know
where the free space is.
This is a camera from the
side, with a fish eye.
Again, using the same kind
of technology the system
can know where
the free space is.
Same thing here.
Here as well, day night.
3D modeling, 3D
modeling is to be
able to put a bounding
box, a 3D bounding box,
around the vehicle.
And the color here is that the
green is front, red is rear,
blue is right hand side, and
yellow is left hand side.
If you let this run--
all right.
Now the importance of
putting a 3D bounding
box around the vehicle
is that now you can
place a camera at any angle.
So it's not only
camera looking forward,
but the camera at any
angle, because the way
a vehicle is defined is
invariant to the camera
position, so this is kind of a
preparation for putting cameras
all around the
vehicle at the 360--
360 degree.
Scene recognition,
for example, being--
to know that this
is a bump, is also
being done by a network
that takes an image
and outputs where the bumps are.
The same thing--
same thing here.
More complicated than that is
knowing where this top line is.
So when you go and detect
traffic lights-- so
detecting traffic lights
is the easy problem.
A more complicated
problem is to know
the relevancy of the traffic
lights, which traffic light is
relevant to what direction.
The third one, the
most difficult problem,
is to detect the stop line.
The problem with stop line is
that when you see the stop line
it's a bit too late.
You see this stop line
20-30 meters away.
So it's too late
to start stopping
and have a smooth stopping.
You want to predict where the
stop line is 60-70 meters away.
So here, you want your
algorithm, or your network,
to understand that you
are approaching a junction
and start estimating where the
stop line should be so they can
start slowly reducing your
speed, such that by the time
you see where the
stop line is you
already reduced your
speed considerably.
I'll skip this.
Knowing lane assignment.
Knowing how many lanes
are and which lane you are
is also done by a network.
So the network will
give a probability
whether that this is a
lane, this is a lane.
For example, it knows
that this is not a lane.
It has here red,
zero probability.
So as you can see here--
I'll skip this one.
So these networks, so for
every task there is a network.
And these networks are quite
sophisticated in accessing,
integrating a context
at traffic light.
I'll skip this
with traffic light.
So multiple cameras,
this is how it is--
it looks like.
You have the red ones are three
cameras behind the windscreen.
One is about 180 degrees.
The other one is about 50.
The third one is
about 25 degrees.
And then there are
another five cameras
around the car that give
you all 360 degrees.
And this kind of configuration,
first launch of it,
in a series produced
car, is going to be 2016.
So I'm not talking
about science fiction.
These are how images look
from some of these cameras.
So let me show you a first
clip of automated driving.
This is kind of a funny--
funny clip.
This is an actor who played
a major role in Star Trek.
So I'll not say his name.
Let's see whether you can
identify him yourself.
And he has a program
called-- program
for kids called Reading Rainbow.
So this program is 20 years old.
And he came to
Israel and he wanted
to drive the autonomous vehicle
that we have for his kids
program.
So he was driving my car.
So my car is autonomous.
I can drive from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem
without touching
the steering wheel.
It's-- I do that all the time.
So he was driving it.
And it's a bit funny.
So let's-- but you'll get
a feeling of what this is.
So let's run this.
It's two minutes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Yes.
They can.
That's because
technology companies,
like Mobileye here
in Israel, are
about to introduce self-driving
technologies to the world.
AMNON SHASHUA: You
know who he is?
- In the not too
distant future, just
like in a science fiction movie.
A driver will be
able to hop in a car,
tell it where you want
it to go, and voila,
the car will do the rest.
So right now I'm driving
like everybody does.
My hands are on
the steering wheel
and my foot is on the brake,
or the pedal, as required.
And I'm in control of the car.
But when I take my foot
off the pedal and do this,
now the car is driving itself.
Wow.
This really is amazing.
I feel really safe with the
car doing all of the driving.
OK.
Now watch this.
And this is something
that no one should ever
do in a regular car, ever.
Wow.
That was freaky.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMNON SHASHUA: OK?
So anyone from the young
people know who he is?
So this is Jordy,
from Star Trek.
He had this visor.
He was blind.
He had a visor.
OK.
So let's spend a
few minutes to talk
about what is the impact
of autonomous driving
and how it's going to unfold.
So this is far from
science fiction.
It's actually
unfolding as we speak.
The first hands free driving
on highways is coming out now.
The first one is Tesla.
They have already launched--
they made this public
a week or two ago.
Their first beta drivers
are driving with the system.
And I presume within a month
it will be also installed
to all other drivers.
And this is-- you
can do hands free
when driving on a
highway, unlimited speed.
So you can drive
at highway speeds,
let go of the steering wheel,
and the car will drive.
GM already announced
that middle of 2016
they have the super
cruise, more or less
the same kind of functionality.
Audi also announced 2016.
And these are just
the first comers.
We are working with about
13 car manufacturers that
within the next three
years, three to four years,
having this kind of capability.
So this will be
in the mainstream.
Now what I put there in
red is that the driver
still has primary responsibility
and has to be alert.
That means that the
technology is not perfect.
It could make mistakes.
Therefore, the
driver has to be--
is still the primary--
has the primary responsibility.
So at this stage there's
no disruption here.
It's just a nice
feature to have.
For the car industry,
this is the first step
to start practicing towards
reaching autonomous driving.
The second step starts 2016, and
this is with the eight cameras
that I showed you slide before.
Here, the car can drive
autonomously from highway
to highway.
So on ramp, off ramps,
are done autonomously.
So you-- you with Google Maps or
whatever navigation program you
chart your route, and until the
car reaches city boundaries it
will go all--
go autonomously.
From highway to highway it will
switch from highway to highway
and do that autonomously.
Still, the driver has primary
responsibility, and is alert.
So there's no-- nothing
here is transformative.
It's a nice feature.
Again, it's part of a phased
approach of the car industry
to start practicing.
Starting from 2018, would come
the first small disruption.
The first small disruption
is that technology
would reach a level in
which driver is responsible.
The driver must be there
but not necessarily alert.
So it means that the
driver is an attendant.
The driver is monitoring
just like a pilot
sitting in an airplane while
the plane is in auto-pilot.
The driver needs to be there
in case there is a problem.
The system will give
a grace period of time
until the driver needs
to take back control.
So it's not taking control
in instant-- immediately.
And so this transition
from primary responsibility
to monitoring, like
in aviation, will be
the first disruption, the
beginnings of a disruption.
So let's try to imagine what
kind of disruption this is.
So let's take Uber
as an example.
So today you have free time.
So you own a car.
You have a free time, say
between 3:00 PM to 5:00 PM
So you take your car and
apply Uber and take passengers
and earn some money.
That's Uber today.
Now let's look at 2018 - 2019.
You have zero skills and
you don't have a car.
All what you have, you
have a driver license.
So you are willing
to be an attendant.
So you say, OK, now
I have free time.
An Uber car would come
with an attendant.
You switch places
with the attendant.
You sit behind the steering
wheel and you do nothing.
You don't control the car.
You don't control the
passengers who are coming
who are being taken by the car.
You simply sit there.
Zero skills, therefore your
payment is very, very small.
So now these cars can drive
24/7 because attendant can
be replaced every hour or so.
So here we have
another business model
which makes this public
transportation, the Uber type
of public transportation,
now much more powerful
than it is today.
So this is kind of the
beginning of disruption.
What will be the next step?
The next step 2020-2022,
imagine that a driverless car
can drive without passengers.
So this is one step
before you can allow a car
to drive autonomously.
So without passengers means
that all what you need to prove
is that the car,
your car, would not
hit other cars or pedestrians.
But if it hits an
infrastructure nobody gets
killed because there are
no passengers in the car.
No passengers meaning
nobody in the car.
Now this is already
a major disruption
because what it means, it means
that the household does not
need to own multiple cars.
One car is enough.
I drive to work with the car.
I send the car back home.
Takes my wife, take her
to work, comes back home.
You get the picture.
So this is kind of a beginning
of a major disruption.
Then about 2025 - 2030,
sufficient experience
with mapping data, car
to car communication,
one can imagine how
these cars would
be completely autonomously.
And that is where the
major disruption happens.
OK?
So this is autonomous driving.
Let me go to the second part
about wearable computing.
And then we can take questions.
So this will be much shorter.
So again, computer
vision, but now the camera
is not beside us,
like in the car.
The camera is on us.
Now if the camera is on
us, the first question
that you would ask, who
needs a camera to be on you?
Right?
So the first market segment
for something like this
are the blind and
visually impaired.
So the way to imagine this.
you are visually impaired
or a blind person
so you don't see well
or you don't see at all,
or you don't see well.
So it's very, very
difficult for you
to negotiate the visual world.
You cannot read anything unless
it's few centimeters from
your eye.
You cannot recognize people
unless they start talking
to you.
So you can recognize
their voice.
You cannot cross the street
because you don't see
the traffic light.
You cannot go on a bus because
you don't think what the bus
number is.
So basically you are very,
very constrained, very limited.
Now let's assume that you have
a helper standing beside you.
Now this helper is
relatively intelligent
and has correct eyesight.
Now the helper
looks at you, sees
where you are pointing
your hands, for example,
or pointing your gaze,
looks at the scene,
understands what kind of
information you want to know,
and whispers to your
ear the information.
So say you want to catch a bus.
You know that the bus is coming
because you hear the bus,
maybe you see a silhouette.
So you look at that direction.
The helper looks at the bus.
It sees that there is a bus.
Tells you what
the bus number is.
You want to cross the street.
You know the traffic light
is more or less there.
But you cannot-- you don't know
what the color of the traffic
light is.
So the helper
looks at your gaze,
sees that there's a
traffic light there.
Tell you it's a green light.
You're opening a newspaper.
You point someone
on the newspaper,
the helper would
read you the article.
Or there is a street name.
You point towards
the street name.
The helper would
look at the scene,
understand that there
is a text in the wild,
and simply read you
the street name.
A familiar face appears,
the helper will whisper,
you know, Joe has now--
is now in front of you.
And so forth.
So if you have now replaced
this helper with computer vision
you can imagine how
this could help someone
who is visually impaired.
So let me show you--
so first of all, the number of
visually impaired is quite big.
So the number of blind people
in the US is about 1.5 million.
That's not big.
The number of visually
impaired, and it's people that
their ailment cannot be
corrected through lenses,
is about 26 million.
So this is a sizable number.
World wide is above
400 million people
who are visually impaired.
And they don't have much
technology to help them.
So this is what OrCam is doing.
It's a camera which
clips on eyeglasses.
And there is a computing device,
which you put in your pocket.
And the way you interact with
the device is with your hand,
with your finger.
Because the camera is on you
it could see also your hand.
Once you point,
the camera starts
to extract information
from the scene and talks
to you through an earpiece.
So let's look at the clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi.
I'm Liette and I'm
visually impaired.
I want to show you today how
this device changed my life.
- Massaryk.
- Great.
Let's go there.
- Red light.
Green light.
50 shekel.
- 50 shekel.
Let's buy some coffee.
- Breakfast.
Bagel plus coffee with
cream cheese [INAUDIBLE]..
[END PLAYBACK]
AMNON SHASHUA: OK?
So you get the idea.
So we started 2010.
2013 we had already
a prototype working.
And we had a visitor, John
Mark from the New York Times,
and he came and he wrote
a very nice article
about what the company is doing.
And we thought that
at that time it
would be good to launch
the website of the company
and try to get a number,
say, 100 first customers,
so that we can start
experimenting, do field studies
with a prototype device.
So we launched the web site.
We wrote that the
device cost $2,500.
That was June 2013.
And the first 100 people who
would purchase the device
will receive the
device in September.
So within an hour those
100 devices were sold.
And then we kept a waiting list,
which today is about 30,000.
And we started shipping the
devices about a month ago.
So in the last year this device
was with about 200 people.
And we got a lot of feedback
from real users and improved.
And let me show you
some real users.
So this is Marcia from Brazil.
The device at the moment
only works in English.
Later we'll put more languages.
And so she's being
trained to use a device.
And this is a short clip
of about two minutes.
And, you know, watch
her body language.
And also she explains
how she copes
with her disability, especially
how she distinguishes
between different money notes.
They're all green.
So how do you
distinguish between them?
So let's have a look at this.
So the device is reading
the newspaper for her.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE]
- $50.
Cincuenta dollars.
- Cincuenta.
Let's see if [INAUDIBLE].
- It green.
All green and I put mark
color, yellow, green, orange.
Different note.
[INAUDIBLE]
- $20.
[? Genia ?]
- [INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
AMNON SHASHUA: OK.
Here's a recent-- from CNN.
It was aired a month ago.
It also gives a bit more
information about the device.
Let's run this.
It's again two minutes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Two weekends ago I sat down
and read The New York Times.
I haven't done that
in maybe 30 years.
My wife came down.
I had a cup of coffee.
I'm reading The New York
Times and she was crying.
- Just being able to read again
is emotional for Howard Turman.
He started losing his
vision as a child.
His new glasses
don't fix his eyes
but they do the next best thing.
- Put on my glasses, it
recognizes the finger,
snaps the picture.
Now it just reads.
- The glasses have a camera
that recognizes text and can
read the world to him.
- Pull here.
- The technology is called OrCam
and Turman says it gives him
a sense of normalcy.
- Even finding out that Dunkin'
Donuts has a donut I never
tried was exciting.
- Dunkin' Donuts.
- It's a clip on camera.
So a camera that you can
clip onto any eyeglasses.
And you have here a
computing device, which
you can put in your pocket.
And the way it interacts,
it's with a hand gesture.
For example, it's written
there, rental and tours.
- Rentals and tours.
- It's not perfect though.
It uses a pretty bulky
cable and sometimes it
needs a few tries
to get things right.
- It doesn't read script
because everybody's handwriting
is different.
So it doesn't do cursive
very well at all.
- OrCam has a harder
time in bright light,
or in tougher situations,
like signs on windows.
- [INAUDIBLE] U donuts
hours of operation.
Low PM.
Pound's PM.
9:00 PM.
How was your service today?
- Shashua says improvements
are on the way.
Where do you see this technology
going over the long term?
- Reading, recognizing
faces, recognizing products,
is only the beginning.
Where we want to get is
complete visual understanding
at the level of
human perception,
such that if you
are disoriented you
can start understanding
what's around you.
For example, where's the door?
The door is there.
Where is the window?
Where is an opening in
the space around me?
OK?
This is face recognition.
So again, one of the first 100.
- Teach OrCam to
recognize anybody?
- Yep.
- Who does it know?
- Libby, my mother.
- You want to show me?
- Yep.
OK.
- All right.
[INAUDIBLE] Let's see.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Libby.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMNON SHASHUA: OK?
So that's also face recognition.
Last two slides.
We started also providing the
device to research groups.
And this is one of-- this is
a paper in ARVO where they
took eight visually
impaired and gave them
the device for one month.
And then measured the
change in quality of life.
And how they measure the
change of quality of life,
they interview them.
And seven out of the eight
reported significant change
in quality of life.
Now they sent us some
of the interviews.
So on the next--
here, I'm showing you
part of the interview.
And what's interesting
about this interview
is that there is
a trick question.
The interviewer,
after she tells him
how the device is,
you know, lifesaving
and so forth, he tells her, well
the device is very expensive.
It's a few thousands of dollars.
Is it worth it?
So it's one thing to get
something for free and say,
it's very, very good.
Another thing's is it's going to
cost you thousands of dollars,
is it worth it?
And let's hear her answer,
which is very nice.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In the first few
days I had the OrCam
I was in total awe of it
because for the first time
I was able to open
mail and read it,
instead of having my
husband read my mail.
And I was able to
go to a restaurant
and actually read the menu and
order myself with the waitress.
And that was exciting.
When you can't do something
for such a long period of time,
the OrCam was incredible.
- Believe is what
the estimate is.
Do you think such
a high price would
be something people
would be willing to pay
for a device like this?
Do you think it's marginally
worth it right now?
- I think you're going
to find that that's going
to be on a case by case basis.
You know, people who have
money there's certainly
no problem $2,000.
I don't have money.
I am low income.
But I would save my money,
scrape it together in order
to get it at $2,000.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMNON SHASHUA: So
that's interesting.
Where is it going?
So there are two
lines of progress.
One, is when this
existing niche is
to make the camera understand
the visual field at higher
levels of detail.
So one of the things that
we are now working on
is, we call this chatting mode.
So it's like-- it's
the image and notation
type of experiment, or
the ImageNet together
with natural
language processing.
Say you are visually impaired
or blind and you're disoriented.
You don't know where you are.
So you would like
the device to tell
you every second what it sees.
I see here Tommy.
I see here chairs.
I see here another person.
I see here a wall, an opening,
a painting, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, until you get back
your sense of orientation.
So you want the device
to be able to have
say, several thousands
of categories,
like in ImageNet, together with
image annotation capability.
The kind of stuff that people
are now writing articles about.
And being able to do
this at the frame rate of
say, once per second.
So wherever I'm looking
at tell me what--
what you see.
This is one-- another thing
is to have natural language
processing, NLP ability.
For example, if you are
looking at an electricity bill.
The system would
know that you're
looking at an electricity bill
and give you just the short--
what is the amount
due, for example.
The system will tell you are
looking at an electricity bill.
The amount due is such and such.
So having more and more
intelligence into the system.
So this is one area.
Another area is to go for a
wearable device for people
with normal sight.
So here we're talking about, you
know, real wearable computing.
So this Apple Watch
is wearable computing.
But doesn't do much computing.
Right?
It displays, you know my text
messages, emails, you know,
measures certain biometrics.
But that's not, you
know, the holy grail
of wearable computing.
The holy grail of
wearable computing
is assume that you had
Siri with eyes and ears.
So you had a camera on you
that is observing the scene all
the time and providing you
real time information whenever
you need the information,
like the people that you meet.
What were the recent tweets
of those people that you met?
What is common
between you and them
based on Facebook and
LinkedIn and so forth?
So knowing more about
the people you meet.
Knowing more about the
stuff that you are doing.
And creating an
archive of all what you
are doing throughout the day.
And this is a device like this.
This is how it looks like.
We call it Cassie.
So this is a real device.
It works continuously
for about 13 hours.
So you have a camera working
continuously for 13 hours.
And the purpose of this camera--
so the way-- you
put it like this.
OK?
So the purpose of the camera
is not to take pictures.
It doesn't store any picture.
The purpose of the
camera is to be a sensor,
is to interpret the visual
world and provide information
in real time.
And if everything
goes well, we'll
start launching this
within six months from now.
So this is the next big thing,
to go into wearable computing,
to go into a domain in which a
camera is on you and processing
information all the time.
Unlike now, a camera on
your smartphone in which
you take a picture on demand.
It's not working for
you all the time.
Here it's working
for me all the time.
All the time it's
viewing the visual field.
Whenever it finds
something interesting
it will send it
to my smartphone,
like people that I meet and
other activities that I do.
So this will be the beginning
of real wearable computing.
So wearable computing
with sensing,
with the ability to hear
and listen, to hear and see,
and process information
in real time.
This is the next thing that--
the next big challenge
that we are working on.